la chute du tourisme et de l'aérien
contraintes sanitaires nouveaux modes de
consommation l'épidémie de coronavirus
bouleverse bon nombre de modèles
économiques
certains secteurs sont déjà au tapis
alors que d'autres pourrait en sortir
renforcé alors question quels seront les
gagnants quels seront les perdants de
cette crise et avec quelles conséquences
économiques on voit cela tout de suite
avec vous jacques sapir que l'on
retrouve en duplex de nos studios de
caumartin bonsoir jacques alors soir
stéphanie alors jacques cette crise donc
économique aura ses perdants et ses
gagnants comme chaque crise à quelle
redistribution des cartes peut-on
s'attendre
oui c'est évident parce que cette crise
et on voit très bien qu'il ya trois
facteurs il ya évidemment le confinement
il y a après l'arrêt des transports
et puis il y aussi la crainte d'un re
démarrage justement de cet été
tout ceci a un impact extrêmement
important sur l'activité économique
alors oui il va y avoir malheureusement
des perdants pense au tourisme même pas
eu il ya l'automobile
il ya aussi un secteur à haute
technologie comme le secteur aérien à la
fois en transport et en industrie
aérospatiale et puis d'un autre côté il
n'y aura très probablement des gagnants
comme le secteur de l'économie de la
santé mais aussi l'ensemble du commerce
électronique ce qu'on appelle le
e-commerce voir d'autres secteurs
commençons par les paires dont vous avez
cité le tourisme qu'en est il alors oui
c'est évident le tourisme qui est un
secteur économique important
un type pèse d'ailleurs en france va
être très touché par la crise vous savez
le tourisme ça représente à peu de
choses près 7 points du pib 7% du pib
mais un peu plus de 10% de l'emploi
privé donc on voit bien que c'est un
secteur important et malheureusement on
sait que ce secteur va souffrir de la
crise
jacques en raison des mesures de
protection et des restrictions
d'ouverture des restaurants
they les plages oui oui stéphanie c'est
évident mais il n'y a que ça vous savez
la france est une destination
touristique importante elle recevait
tous les ans à peu près 90 millions de
touristes étrangers
or cette année en mettant les choses au
mieux on devrait être à 20 millions de
touristes étrangers
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pas ça veut
dire qu'il va y avoir une baisse
importante de clientèle dans toute une
série de tout ce que l'on visite alors
ça peut être évidemment le parc
disneyland mais c'est quand même aussi
le château de versailles
c'est la tour eiffel près derrière ces
grands lieux que l'on visite qu'est ce
qu'il y a il ya quand même des entités
alors qu'elles soient privées comme
disneyland qu'elle soit publique
l'établissement du louvre par exemple et
ses entités
eh bien elle emploie des milliers de
gens prenez par exemple vous avez le puy
du fou 2000 salariés donc tout ceci fait
que le choc lié à l'absence des
touristes étrangers va être très
durement ressentie et si on ajoute à ça
évidemment l'impact sur l'hôtellerie sur
la restauration qui au mieux ne
repartira qu'à moitié voire aux deux
tiers de sa capacité
on voit qu'il va y avoir une perte
d'emploi importantes dans tous les
emplois saisonniers qui était justement
l'une des bases essentielles de
l'activité dans ce secteur par ailleurs
il faut ajouter que il ya un autre
secteur qui va être très touché c'est la
restauration d'entreprise parce que
beaucoup d'entreprises vont rester en
télétravail peut-être pas totalement
mais vont rester en parquet en
télétravail et cela bien entendu aura
comme conséquence une baisse de
l'activité de l'ensemble des entreprises
de la restauration collective
alors vous nous dites aussi jacques ce
phénomène va toucher des secteurs à
haute technologie wii est le premier
secteur c'est évidemment le secteur de
l'aéronautique alors pourquoi il faut
savoir que d'abord cette crise avait un
impact immédiat sur le transport aérien
or le transport aérien c'est quoi
c'était grosso modo 160 millions de
voyageurs qui partait de la france les
français des étrangers qui rentrait ses
neveux bon mais voilà il ya
un nombre de voyageurs extrêmement
important là aussi on peut s'attendre à
une baisse de 50% voire plus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que certaines compagnies aériennes vont
faire faillite des petites ou des
compagnies aériennes de taille moyenne
dont tout le secteur en appel le secteur
du low cost et bien c'est le modèle
général le modèle économique de ce
secteur qui est remis en cause parce que
faire du low cost
si vous maintenez la distanciation
physique dans les avions
sarr est très très très difficile or
qu'est ce que ça implique et bien ça
implique évidemment une moindre demande
d'avions la demande d'avions va baisser
il ya toute une série de commandes qui
vont être annulées et évidemment savoir
un ça va avoir un impact sur la
construction mais aussi et c'est très
important sur l'ensemble des
sous-traitants de ce secteur
jacques et c'est précisément un secteur
où la place de la france était plutôt on
peut le dire traditionnellement forte
oui elle était traditionnellement forte
elle est toujours traditionnellement
forte
si vous voulez mais il faut aussi
comprendre une chose c'est que c'est un
secteur qui est géographiquement très
concentré pour dire les choses un peu
rapidement c'est ce qu'on appelle le
grand sud ouest et dans ce grand sud
ouest et bien vous voyez on a environ
160 mille travailleurs qui ne sont dans
ce secteur dont 122 milles directement
or malheureusement on peut penser qu'il
y aura entre un cas où un tiers de mise
en somme mise au chômage
donc vous voyez des il va y avoir une
perte d'emploi importantes et cette
perte d'emploi aura un effet boule de
neige sur toute une série d'autres
emplois alors par ailleurs il faut aussi
évidemment dire une chose c'est que ça
va entraîner une forme de
restructuration
pour l'instant le secteur de la
construction aérospatiale et est portée
essentiellement par des activités
civiles des activités privées désormais
ce seront plutôt des activités
militaires qui vont donner le ton qui
vont donner le la à ce secteur et donc
il va y avoir là un vrai problème pour
chercher à éviter qu'une partie de ces
emplois qui risquent d'être perdus ne le
soit pas pourquoi parce que on est en
présence de travailleurs dont les
compétences sont
extrêmement spécialisé jacques est ce
que ce sont les seules victimes et seuls
qui vont souffrir
hélas non hélas non on sait qu'il y aura
d'autres secteurs qui vont être affectés
en particulier évidemment le secteur de
l'automobile mais aussi c'est un point
important le secteur de la grande
distribution est d'ores et déjà on voit
qu'il ya un certain nombre de grandes
enseignes qui soit sont en faillite
choix sont en grande difficulté alors
jacques vous nous aviez promis quand
même il y aurait également des gagnants
oui tout à fait et je voudrais aussi
apporté là peut-être une petite pointe
d'optimisme alors il y aura des gagnants
dans trois secteurs
premier secteur c'est évidemment toute
l'économie de la santé ça va de la
pharmacie la parapharmacie évidemment
par exemple et parce que les tests
étaient terrain mais aussi l'industrie
du logiciel les logiciels de diagnostic
à distance pour tout ce secteur va
connaître une demande très forte et va
connaître à l'évidence un soutien
important de l'état temps plein il est
clair que ce secteur il va plutôt
recruter et embaucher un deuxième
secteur 1 qui va connaître un
développement important
c'est évidemment ce qu'on appelle le
e-commerce on voit bien et ça a déjà
commencé pendant le confinement que
toutes les grandes sociétés de
e-commerce et bien elles tirent mieux
leur épingle du jeu que le commerce
traditionnel
et puis un troisième secteur et ça c'est
un petit peu plus étonnant mais c'est
intéressant c'est le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire c'est le secteur de
l'alimentation pourquoi parce que au
travers du confinant au travers de cette
crise
eh bien il semble que les français hills
et retrouver le goût de manger français
ou en tous les cas d'avoir recours
plutôt à des productions locales et tout
ceci bien sûr ça a un coût ça veut dire
que on accepte de payer un peu plus cher
les produits mais ça va très
certainement renforcer l'agriculture et
l'ensemble du secteur agroalimentaire
qui va avec alors la conclusion qu
est-ce que cela implique-t-il pour
l'économie
eh bien première chose qu'il faut dire
c'est que cette crise c'est pas
simplement un choc économique
c'est une véritable transformation il ya
des secteurs qui vont se rétracter qui
vont dépérir et pour plusieurs années
peut-être une dizaine d'années c'est une
évidence d'autres secteurs qui vont
connaître comme je viens de vous
l'expliquer un développement extrêmement
important donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point et qui me semble
important c'est que malheureusement
entre les secteurs que j'appelle un
petit peu rapidement les secteurs
perdants et les secteurs gagnants
eh bien il n'y a pas égalité en matière
d'emploi et ça pose un véritable
problème
il va falloir trouver des emplois pour
tous ces personnels qui vont être
licenciés dans le secteur du tourisme de
la restauration mais aussi tous et tous
ces travailleurs qui risquent de perdre
leur emploi par exemple dont
l'automobile ou dans l'aéronautique aimé
ça m'amène à une troisième contestation
c'est le fait que évidemment et bien la
volonté de maintenir un certain nombre
d'emplois ne serait ce que pour que à
savoir faire ne se perdent pas eh bien
ça va entraîner une intervention qu'elle
soit directe moins directe de l'état
de plus en plus importante dans
l'économie eh bien merci jacques canteau
ses explications éclairante sur ce qui
nous attend mais aussi à vous